what's up
guys bang bang it's lunch money time
well while she's trying to get rich the
rest of us trying to get our lunch money
right
i'm here with the beautiful intelligent
playing the evilova marinova looks like
a
dalmatian
no no this is a cheetah or a cheetah
same thing who's paying attention
not me don't forget that now lunch money
is sponsored by block five block five
has three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange go do it you can deposit
crypto and take out a us dollar loan
against your crypto collateral
go do it or you can use their interest
bearing accounts that's my favorite
product i'm an investor i sit on the
board i use the product
go and check out their interest bearing
accounts where you can earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest-bearing account go
check it out blockbuy.com
pomp again blockfy.com pomp
go do it what's up hey guys i have a
weird hair sticking up here
so we're just gonna we're just gonna
power through it okay
so there are now some stop spinning your
phone
uh there are now 4.5 million oh no
there are now 4.5 million
people looking for work well but hold on
it's it's that includes 742 000 who have
had temporary jobs come to an end
and 3.8 million who have lost permanent
jobs the number of permanent
job losers among the unemployed has more
than doubled in the last six months
the fastest pace on increa inc of
increase on record
this means that a lot of temporary job
losses are now
permanent yes i told you guys i told you
this was gonna happen in march i wrote
in march i wrote a piece and i said we
may see the greatest unemployment
since the great depression when i wrote
it everyone laughed at me they were like
no way
no way yes way i told you all this was
gonna happen
because all you had to do is just back
into the math hospitality service
industry
uh plus loss in other sectors of course
was going to add up very quickly
if you remember in if i remember the
numbers correctly 1929
we went from 3.1 unemployment to about
8.5 percent then in 1930
we went all the way up to 15
then in 1931 32 uh and i think 33 we
were above
20 unemployment and then we finally came
down so
we went from 3.5 in february a historic
low in unemployment in the united states
to over 10 unemployment
which means that we actually accelerated
faster than we did during the great
depression
that was the whole point they had a bing
bada boom i told you
and i'm taking my victory lap well it's
not really something to celebrate
no but i'm just i but my high school
economics teacher would be having a cow
right about now okay a cow
in in bulgarian cows krava keep going
it's true let's go next yes it's really
great when he starts calling my family
members like farm animals because he
doesn't know any other words so
you are cow is not great um
so from april so the job losses
permanent job losses are getting worse
so does that mean it's because
so many companies are shutting down yeah
so many restaurants and stuff and so
they don't have anybody to bring back
yeah they're not no the restaurants
aren't coming back therefore there's no
jobs
next okay the ceos of facebook google
and twitter have agreed to virtually
testify before the senate commerce
committee on october 28th
they will testify on section 230 of the
communications decency act
which protects tech companies from
liability over the content posted by
users on their online services
did we already do this is this different
yeah but i mean they're going to keep
bringing them in
right this is for the communications
decency act though this isn't for
anti-trust issues
and the whole thing and look trust me if
they say things under oath here then
they're going to use it in the antitrust
thing
so it's a big deal but this is less uh
directly going after the companies and
it's more going after this
section 230 or whatever so i mean can
anybody just uh make them go to these
hearings i feel like they have
bigger better things to do no the
government officials can but they want
they want the ceos there
so that they can uh they're going to
subpoena the ceos if the ceos don't show
up
right so the ceos are going to go
regardless you might as well volunteer
my favorite is uh i'm so excited for
them to be asking
how facebook messenger works and why
suddenly instagram messenger and
facebook messenger have merged people
will be confused
okay next stop it
uh and you see you see her pushing me
out of the camera no you
you pushed me the people will see
nvidia come on nvidia pledges to build
britain's largest super computer
following the 40 billion dollar bid for
arm or was that company backed by
softbank
um so yeah the super computer named
cambridge
one of course that's what it's name is
intended for artificial intelligence
research and healthcare yeah
well the strongest computing network in
the world is bitcoin
but uh this is pretty cool i love this
idea yeah
now it'll be the twitter the most
powerful computer in the world it's only
britain's
most powerful yeah and well that was
gonna be the first point
second point is uh artificial
intelligence doesn't actually exist
so that's kind of a headline grabber
that might be a little misleading
it's probably more machine learning that
they're talking about
uh and three is uh they you have this
quote it says there are scientists that
need a state-of-the-art computer and
we're going to build
one and they're going to do large-scale
research and they that they otherwise
wouldn't be able to do
yeah that's great like that's exactly
what a computer is supposed to do put a
bunch of data in
have it synthesize it and make a bunch
of computations and kick you out
answers do you know what a petaflop is
oh that's a lot of data
oh really yeah oh so cambridge one will
have 400 petaflops of ai performance
in that it will rank in the top three
most energy efficient supercomputers in
the world
a petaflop is a measure of a computer's
processing speed
so how fast yeah so all right
i like it get the super computers up and
running we're just in the new digital
arms race for super computing power
across countries but as you see britain
is really ambitious they're only trying
to build the 29th most powerful one
okay so i've written about this before
i'm so excited next
well this is what is next i like that's
like saying that
i love her venmo launches
its first credit card with a scannable
qr code and personalized cashback
rewards
i wrote about this when margaret keane
was one of the top business people uh
according to fortune and synchrony
financial
she is the ceo um partnered with venmo
to create the first
venmo debit card and now the credit card
i mean look they've got to do this
everyone's going to continue to push
into trying to be a bank and
create some sort of financial services
but at the end of the day the writing's
on the wall we're moving to digital
currencies
venmo needs to get on board or they're
going to get
left behind i think it's cool that
synchrony is doing it because
in recent years they've really ramped up
their tech investment
so that's how they won the venmo deal if
anybody was interested
uh that's great and also benmo is trying
to do more with crypto so
shout out to those folks i think they're
trying to power i think it's venmo and
paypal are trying to add in
a lot of crypto support uh but look
again this goes to the whole idea like
it's the financialization of everything
every company is trying to get into
uh banking venmo obviously was already
in payment so it's very easy for them to
kind of
laterally move in as i've talked about
and they have a younger
base of customers yeah they definitely
do uh
but i actually would love to see the age
demographic because my guess is that
venmo's demographic is older than cash
app
yeah it's millennials it's not well
maybe it is
like people like me you know like old
people it's like
late 20s early 30s yeah and up right
because those people when they were 25
or 20 or whatever they brought their
parents on to it and stuff
but i think the younger generation if i
had to guess more of them have flowed to
cash up than venmo but who knows
all right what you got next regal
cinemas to shut down
uh all locations in the us temporarily
the second largest u.s cinema chain is
looking at closing
is closing its doors again as high
profile movies
vacate the calendar oh man they got no
customers they got no movies
well the movies are vacating it and not
releasing because they're realizing
they're not getting the box office
uh revenue that they used to get so
remember that
it was the third week in march if i
remember the numbers correctly the third
week in march
the movie sales for the us box office in
2019 so last year
uh was over 200 million dollars in the
third week in march that's like what all
the shelter in place went in order and
stuff in the united states
uh this this year there was only five
thousand dollars going from 200 million
dropped all the way down u.s box office
sales to five thousand dollars
and so what you end up realizing is like
it was a 99
loss in revenue for the us box office in
that one week right year over year
and so that's why these people are all
saying why are we going to release our
movies right now
there's no audience so the well and also
there's no movies the ceo of cineworld
said we are like a grocery shop that
doesn't have vegetables fruit
meat we cannot operate for a long time
without a product
yeah if i was a movie theater and i
thought it was safe and had a way to do
it
you know what i would do 90s movies
disney movies
i would try to figure out uh all kinds
of interesting ways
to play old school movies like i would
do like
people are doing that with the drive-in
movie theaters yeah drive-ins but like
go in person
i don't know if i'd go to an in-person
movie theater right now just from like a
health standpoint
but uh i do think that it would be
interesting if you did like a
all-day uh marathon
of like whatever and you like had like
really cool food to serve people
and people could just get drunk and
watch movies the whole time one time i
was at the dmv for like four hours
and anthony came to meet me and
surprised me with
what i don't remember oh lion king in 3d
i was like oh okay yeah lion king and
three leaving
if i was in california i'd let people
just come in and i'd be like we we'd
call it like uh
wake bacon movies and you could just
show up started at 9am and you just
smoked weed the whole day and you could
watch movies there the whole time
sales would be through the roof i got
all kinds of i would not be a
participant
uh sec is willing to try a tokenized etf
the chairman says you wrote about this
this morning in your lovely newsletter
that i read
every single day what did you say told
you
that's basically what i said told you
every stock bond currency and commodity
will be digitized in the future
uh the timeline when that happens yes to
be seen
sec chairman jake clayton says that he's
open to the idea of a tokenized
exchange-traded fund an etf
he said we're willing to try that our
door is wide open
uh that's basically what he said yeah no
it's just every stockpile currency claim
is going to be digitized the question is
how long does it take and what
blockchain does it happen on right and
what i wrote about this morning is like
the market will decide what my personal
opinion is does it matter what yours is
doesn't matter
uh i personally believe it's going to
happen on bitcoin we'll see what happens
um but the market is being made by
people betting trillions of dollars well
billions of dollars really
uh right now on what's gonna occur in
the future so great
so if you've got an opinion don't tell
me about it just go
put your bet down on the market and see
what happens put your bed down
yeah fortunes will be made wealth will
be destroyed that's how cycles work
my math teacher called me average is
this your joke yes
my math teacher called me average
how mean
i got to get better ones but like it's
just we're running you're not even
you're not even doing dad jokes anymore
now you're doing nerd jokes
and there's nothing worse than a not
funny nerd joke you're a not funny nerd
so but i don't tell nerd jokes i tell
inappropriate jokes and when i tell
inappropriate jokes people laugh you
know why
because everybody likes inappropriate
jokes yeah because they're like in
middle school
yeah everyone's a kid that's fine it
didn't matter if you're 70
or you're 16. if you hear an
inappropriate joke you laugh
i like my nerd jokes all right well
nerds
and those who like inappropriate jokes
we'll see you guys tomorrow see ya
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block fly's my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends